in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Dan and
Jamie are with us hey guys how are you
doing great how are you better than I
deserve welcome where y'all from Spokane
Washington
whoa why don't we do a transcontinental
trip to get that free scream my sister
lives in town so we thought we'd oh
there's the real reason okay come visit
Susan while we're here we'll book our
debt free scream I like it so how much
dad have y'all paid off a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars Wow
excellent making what kind of money we
started out five years ago making 35,000
and now well we went after 115 then back
down to 95 Wow okay and how long did
this take you to pay this off well five
years five years okay very cool what do
y'all do for a living I'm an analyst
programmer mm-hmm and I'm a retirement
planning consultant okay very cool good
for you guys
fun fun so a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars well my bet is this well it's a
lot of me it's a lot of student loans
from seminary actually uh-huh and and
then the rest was our house okay all
right so you paid off your home yep we
did you have no house payment no no how
old are you - 36 you're so weird
yep that's awesome we've heard that a
lot congratulations so what's the house
worth oh by about 150,000 okay very cool
very cool good for you how does it feel
to have a paid-for house well we're kind
of getting used to how you feel Jamie
not a whole lot different than how it
was before I guess but I like it a lot
he likes a lot it really was a lot of
stress from him yeah that part is really
good yeah very cool so tell me the story
what happened five years ago tell me
about your journey well five years ago I
am I left work in ministry to go pay off
my student loans and at the same time
that was going on we were going through
miscarriage after miscarriage so I felt
like we wanted to start a family that
side of my life wasn't working out so I
went to work to pay off my debt and then
two years later we had Nash and we found
out Nash has Down syndrome when he was
born and we just felt like the whole
financial side of our life was the one
thing we could have control over well
everything else wasn't working out
okay and then you had another baby we
did and other babies names what el el
and how old is el about seven months Oh
fine very cool all right and so you you
basically just said the math isn't
working I'm gonna go make some money and
make the math work correct
okay so Jamie he comes in and starts
talking about that tell me what happened
well I don't really know I mean we I
think we both naturally a little bit on
the nerd side and um we're both pretty
content with our lives and almost to the
extent that maybe a little bit lazy and
so we we like our house we like our 20
year old cars you like I kind of feel
like God kind of loved and fished us
anyway um this seemed a lot sorry to say
but kind of easier than I feel like it
should have been and I don't know it we
did it and we got a plan and we we
really just kind of stuck to it and our
plan changed over the course of the time
but we knew what it was and we did it I
think felt easy because everything else
in our life was really hard yeah you
know so your plan gave us a way to have
control over something in our life and
like Jamie said God just blessed us to
the point where he took away all those
worries I had of my student loans and
how can I be a pastor if we have these
student loans and then we want to start
a family and he just provided for us so
I'm very thankful and how did you get
intersected with us
well we found you about halfway through
the process the Total Money Makeover
book I picked that up at the bookstore I
started reading it because I was kind of
trying to do everything at once trying
to retirement and saving and take care
of my student loans a little bit by a
little bit but you're playing just gave
us a way to do everything step by step
and get it done and that helped give you
traction a sense of traction yeah and
you know once I got rid of my student
loans there initially I had no idea that
I could path my house I mean like who
does that yeah really and we just kept
going and said it's it's working so
let's just keep doing it I know who does
that you did very cool Chris oh man
that's so it's so great I'm so proud of
you guys way to go congratulations you
know
for our listeners I think it's I think
it's very important for us to realize
that that contentment is a big piece of
that you kind of just skimmed over that
but you said it was relatively easy but
if we go back to our belief system and
we truly are content and not entitled
that just makes such a tremendous
difference
you guys got four or five thousand
dollars in discretionary money every
month now so what are you doing what's
the plan well we're putting a little bit
aside for a new car because we have some
Dave cars we have three cars for two
people breaks down you have a spare yeah
20 years old I became quite the shade
tree mechanic when I was going through
this you know fixing things on one car
while the other car was working and this
and that and the other so that's that
was that was one way to do it yeah so
the first thing is the first order of
business save up some cash and move up a
little bit in your move up in car and
then hopefully move up in house we like
our house right now but you know if we
want a little bit better one a one
that's not so close to a busier Street
for Nash down the road when he's out
running around so that's it very cool
very cool well done you guys so what do
you tell people the secret to getting
out of that is I think having a plan and
sticking with it mm-hmm I know that
people say that a lot on your show but
it it really is true
we we made our budget based on Dan's
income and Dan's income alone and we
didn't have a lot of monthly we don't
have the Internet we didn't have phones
we didn't have you know we don't have
cable TV and stuff like that and so we
made those decisions we made all of our
budget on his salary and then mine is
just extra and she makes more money than
I do so that yeah and so the idea that
maybe someday one of us could stay home
with the kids and which was a really
good plan because now having Down
syndrome he's got a lot of therapies and
stuff like that so damn cut back part
time and so now we're able to do that
well he could stay home with Nash
part-time and I'm I'm working a job that
I love and so very cool yeah just being
out of that gives you way more freedom
in life you know to do what you want to
do you don't have to do what you have to
do you can take carrot you can take care
of what's important yeah so for me I
could take care of Nash and do his
therapy with
and not feel like I have to do
everything you know work and take care
of them and do his therapy and try to
get some sleep at night you know that's
it's hard that's hard as it was to
little kids so sure well congratulations
you two
thank you out of you well done Dan and
Jamie Spokane Washington they paid off
their house and everything
160,000 bucks and five years started off
making 35 then up to 115 and then to 95
now that he's part timing it a little
bit for mr. Nash so count it down let's
hear a great debt free scream all right
three two one
we're debt-free love it love it love it
that's fabulous
you